since landing the role of joy in Blade
Runner 2049 actress rner de Armas has
shot into the spotlight leaving many
sci-fi fans wondering whether they'd
seen her before after starting her
acting career in Cuba they are must hone
their craft in Spain before making the
jump to Hollywood and the English
language films in 2015
here's a look at white joy from Blade
Runner looks so familiar knock knock
Anna de Armas is first widely seen
english-language role came in Eli Roth's
2015 erotic horror film knock knock in
which she terrorizes tortures and abuses
Keanu Reeves character she told screen
rants it was a role she enjoyed it was
so much fun just going from little girls
to pure psycho the armors also enjoyed
making Reeves uncomfortable before the
cameras started rolling he ono is shy
and feels uncomfortable he's not open
about talking about his life in general
so we were really pushing him to the
limit playing with them and touching him
and whispering things to him before the
scene he was really uncomfortable it
really worked exposed after ruling Keanu
Reeves life at knock knock the armors
again teamed up with the soft-spoken
actor in G Malik Linton's 2016 thriller
exposed
she told TV daily that the Reeves taught
her a lot about the craft of acting it's
always very easy to be with him on set
he always wants your work to be better
ken is a great partner grade actor and I
crave producer in this case and a great
friend
Reeves also didn't hold back from
heaping praise on Thomas selling TV
daily when we approached Danna with the
script I was like please say yes it's a
great role than she's remarkable I only
have one scene with her at the end of
the picture which was great but a wish
we'd had more war dogs the Alice's big
2016 wrapped up with a supporting role
in Todd Phillips is biographical drama d
war dogs in which jonah hill and miles
teller get caught up in some super shady
arms-dealing
while exploiting a government initiative
allowing small businesses to win US
military contracts during the Iraq war
they armas told orange magazine she took
the role in part because she wanted to
work with phillips
todd is very smart and what i find so
remarkable about him is his ability to
put movies together that connects so
well with audiences on the sets he knows
what he wants and when you feel that
confidence in your director who is
person telling you what he's looking for
it's amazing overdrive it's been
overshadowed by Blade Runner 2049 but
you may have seen de Armas and the
trailers for overdrive the fact that the
two films opened on the same weekend in
October 2017 just about guaranteed
overdrive would be overlooked but that's
not necessarily a bad thing as overdrive
has been getting terrible reviews the
one bright spot however is a performance
by Thomas who The Hollywood Reporter
said radiates more kickass charisma than
a thankless sidekick role might suggest
hey you can't win em all and given how
many high-profile features they Armas
has already landed she doesn't have to
because Blade Runner 2049 looks like the
beginning of a beautiful blockbuster
career thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know your love to
[Music]